لكن القصه في مخنوقه راويه كما تابعنا على
مدار الايام الماضيه تبدا من سوليدار
فسيطرت روسيا على البلده باتت قريبه بحكم
التطورات الميدانيه على ارض الواقع حتى
وان اجل الصمود الاوكراني الحزم شبكه سي
ان ان نقلت رساله نصيه عن جندي اوكراني في
سوليدار اوضح فيها ان الجنود الروس يشوشون
على الاتصالات الاوكرانيه وان الامر يزداد
سوءا في ظل عدم وجود قاده عسكريين
اوكرانيين بالمنطقه نائبه وزير الدفاع
الاوكرانيه هنا مليار اقرت بان الوضع في
البلده صعب في ظل معاركه هي الاعنف مع
القوه الروسيه واضافت ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تقاتل دون توقفا رغما شراسه
المعركه
ما تزالوا المعارك العنيفه مستمره في
سوليدار بمنطقه باخموت على الرغم من الوضع
الصعب يقاتل الجنود الاوكرانيون بضرواه
العدو الذي يحاول دون جدوى اختراق دفاعنا
والقبض على سوليداره تعاني القوه الروسيه
من خسائر فادحه وتوجد جثثهم داخل المدينه
بتقديم الدعم العسكري لاوكرانيا حيث اعرضت
بولندا عن استعدادها لان تزود كيف باربعه
10 دبابه ثقيله متطوره من نوع ليوبارد تو
على ان يحصل ذلك في اطار تحالف دولي يجري
العمل حاليا على بنائه بدورها اعلنت
ليتوانيا انها سترسل الى اوكرانيا انظمه
مضاده للطائرات من نوع زانهتها
[موسيقى]
هذا التقدم الروسي في دمياط لم يكن بايدي
الجيش وحده بل بسبب الجهود الاكبر التي
كانت لقوات فاتنر الروسيه الخاصه والتي
اعلن قائدها في وقت سابق سيطره قوته على
البلده اضافه الى تجوله في وسط مقاتله في
احد مناجم الملح في سوليدار ليبدو وان
الضوء الاخضر
بعد تعثر الجيش
وما يبرز هذا الامر هو استبدال القيادات
الروسيه بسرعه كبيره ما اظهر تخبطا في
القياده العسكريه الروسيه لم يكن متوقعا
من قوه عسكريه كبرى عاشت على امجاد الجيش
الاحمر الخبر الاهم كان استبدال روسيا من
جديد لقائد قواتها في اوكرانيا لتعين هذه
المره الجنرال فاليري جرسيموف رئيس اركان
القوات المسلحه ق ان العمليه هناك
واكدت الوزاره في بيان ان جراسيموف عين
قائدا لمجموعه القوات المشتركه المنتشره
في اوكرانيا بديلا عن سرجاي سرفيين الذي
تولى المنصب لمده ثلاثه اشهر وبالكات